let's have a look this together part of
the problem is the algebra here you're
like I'm getting caught up in algebra
man algebra is like exploding in my face
okay we've said before right at the
start of year we spent some a good chunk
of time in algebra the primary reason
why we're doing that is because of this
so let's have a look at this together
now the first thing I'm gonna point out
is yes I know doing this expanding this
guy and then expanding both them
together I know it is a very laborious
and disgusting process okay it's part of
why later on in extension 1 we have this
topic called binomial theorem and it
gets you immediately from here down to
this slide here right
I could pair it off to you for example X
plus h ^ I think I could do from memory
up to the power of 6 I can just tell you
all the numbers I can just do them
without having to go through this long
multi-step process because it's it's
gross it's very error-prone and so
because I go up to 6 3 is pretty common
and I can tell you if you want to check
whether you've got your expansion right
this is what you should end up with when
you don't with this X plus h or cute
that's where you should have landed okay
so this represents f of X plus h right
there
okay so when you go ahead and you start
to simplify here's my limit at the front
it'll be that thing but then you take
away X cubed do you see that there's my
take away excuse so I just get left with
this okay this is what I get left with
and then I'm dividing through by H say
it again hold on guys I'm getting some
inconsistent attention here and I'm
really concerned because I know some
people are considering changing subjects
but I'm gonna say it again this is all
in advanced a hundred percent of this is
in advance so he had a question but I
wasn't sure where it was from because
there was too much noise can you repeat
the question there was a thing um that
you said was missing or you're wondering
where it went this guy here you want to
wear that one yeah great question this
this guy here is what happens if you
successfully expand this guy
okay so I'm just saving you some work
down you can check that but once you
take that and you subtract X cubed
that's why there's no X cubes in this
line anymore does that make sense it was
that takeaway X cubed
track you okay great at this point
hopefully if you got this right you're
like oh I have a common factor of H all
the way through so I can just actually
divide my numerator through and this is
what you get
you've got the 3x squared at the front
what comes next
3x h plus h square very good all of that
we now want to consider this whole
object when H gets really teeny tiny if
it gets to zero let's do the easy one
first what happens to H squared when H
gets towards zero this thing's just
going to disappear isn't it right this
guy
this will also because zero times
whatever is still going to give you zero
isn't it so this guy's also going to go
so all you get left with is just three x
squared now let's bring this over let's
do two things number one let's bring
this over to our columns of our
functions and their derivatives and
let's add this to the pile you've got X
cubed and after all of that work
differentiating by first principles
that's what this is called we landed
with this doesn't match what you
expected kind of like for starters right
you notice how a quadratic turned into a
linear linear turned into a horizontal
line another quadratic turn is linear
this is a cubic which turns into a
quadratic now I want you to think for a
second why is that the case
have a look why would it be that's
something which has cubes in it turns
into something with squares you know I
want you to have a look yeah ah see this
guy here see this guy here right it's
really important every time the biggest
term in here ends up canceling in the
previous ones it was an x squared but in
this one at the next kid it's just gone
and then suddenly we're dealing with a
quadratic all the way through right I
wouldn't make you do the one with X to
the power of 4 but look without even
expanding without even
can you see the X to the four term that
comes out of here it's gonna go it's
going to get canceled by that guy does
that make sense don't now secondly let's
actually look at this mrs. Lee's could
have the last place
thank you I think we'll be okay
I think you'll be okay oh that's very
helpful okay let's have a look here's X
cubed right here's execute let's place
three x squared on top of this and see
what we can make of it not lesser-known
squared there we go all right do you
guys see vacu make it out all right so
the red light yeah figure out this right
the red line I need my ruler where's my
ruler go here it is the red line is the
original function the purple line I
should say the purple graph is the
derivative
it's the gradient function right we
differentiated and this is what we've
got okay
now let's think about this the first
thing I notice is this cubic right it's
um it's derivative is always above the
x-axis well except for that spot right
then we'll talk about in a minute so the
derivative is always positive why is
that why is the derivative always
positive what is the derivative tell you
let's think about this there's no point
on the graph this red one where the
gradient of the tangent is ever negative
so here's my tangent okay let's put it
on a place like there like that hey guy
that gradients positive isn't it
yeah how about here gradient still
positive all the way over here great
it's still positive right there and it
just it just keeps on going positive
with one of exception of course which is
right there right the great new here is
not positive if the gradient is zero cuz
flat across there so we have language
for this right we say that this an X
cubed graph we say it is an increasing
function everywhere it's just headed up
right off it goes and that's why it's
derivative is positive okay
it keeps on changing you can think about
going back to for example let's put in
what do we have x squared plus was it 3x
plus 2
plus two and what did we get as our
derivative for that whoops
2x plus 3 right 2 X plus 3 area let's
think about this right have a look at
look at the red graph which is the
original it has a point where it stops
with that tangent is horizontal remember
we called this we gave it a name we call
it a stationary point remember that
there it is right there right
what's the derivative equal to at that
point for that x value the derivative is
right there the derivative the purple
line is 0 right because it sits flat
across there
but this gradient unlike the X cube 1
right this gradient sometimes it goes
down here why would it do that why is
the gradient function down in it very
good these tangent lines right let me
get my tangent again G is this 2g and
its gradient is negative here's another
tangent negative negative keeps going
being her you say that again because
it's so important right at this exact
point where this straight line goes from
negative it transitions over to positive
that's when this was this big original
function it's when it says oh I don't
want to head down in the negative
direction anymore I want to turn around
and go in the positive direction that's
the signal right that's what it says sup
time to go make sense ok yes question
how would you know that the tangent is
going there negative direction going in
there in the previous breath to be x
squared 1 there was a part of the
parabola like like that yep let's go
back there there we go ok fantastically
there's a part of the
okay so you can see I know this is
really tricky right so this purple graph
remember it tells us the gradient okay
let's actually look at a value see this
value right here that my finger is on
its gradient is 4 so that's positive I
know this parabola is going lower but
let's think about what that means right
it's going low but it's still positive
which is why this the tension is still
going up right but let's compare this
actually don't do this way need a bit of
space
let's compare oops this tangent here
there's a tangent at that point there
let's compare briefly with this tangent
here which looks something like that
okay
the gradients of both of these tangents
are both the book positive right because
they're both in the increasing direction
but they're not the same are they right
how would you describe from this one to
this one what's changed
which one's steeper the first one right
so it's steeper here and it becomes
shallower now if you could assign a
number to that right a steeper a steeper
gradient would be a higher number so
that makes this let's say for example a
gradient if say five I have no idea what
actually is we could measure but we
don't need to okay when you have a look
at the gradient here it's shallower it's
still positive so might have a greater
say I don't know a half does that make
sense and what that corresponds to is
when you look up to this point here okay
I didn't pick that five by accident that
five represents where is the gradient
function it's up there at five it's
really high that's why this thing is so
steep right but have a look here see
this where's the gradient function it's
at about surprise surprise about 1/2
because it's like I'm still positive but
just not he's positive I'm so slow right
eventually I get so slow my stop does
that make sense
so it's it's tricky because you're
looking at this thing the purple thing
what you should read off it is not which
way is it facing it's where is it what
is its value is it 5 here's a 2 is it
and that will tell you the direction of
the other graph how's that make sense
okay